welcome back in today's legal minute  we're learning about pool safety laws  eric palacios from eric palacios and  associates the sponsors of this segment  tells us more  i'm eric palacios welcome to the legal  minute this week's question is what are  pool safety laws in nevada number one  you must have a self-closing gate and  this must operate properly  it's a good recommendation to also have  a separate enclosure if you have small  children  it's always important to have an adult  supervising small children  and finally be very careful with doggy  doors crawling children can easily go  out of doggy doors and drown if you have  guests with small children you're always  responsible for their safety  we hope everyone has a safe summer we'll  see you next week here on the legal  minute  and if you want more information give  eric palacios and associates a call at  that phone number 702-444-7777  las vegas